dancing with resistance is what on
today's program the Ecole des saw blade
goes to great lengths to improve the
dancing techniques of its students those
on sampling is I a book with fabula
we're dancing with aunt there's tons of
it here and the whole place the setting
means that the students do everything to
really immerse themselves into working
their body don't collect you go for a 20
students from 15 African countries like
ivory coast and Tanzania have enroll
this year courses are taught in French
and English instructions are given twice
oliva de vago comes from chat where
there's no dance training his commitment
and expression more than make up for his
lack of experience technically see you
working all these dance techniques are
new to me I'm used to the European or
disco dance styles but here I've
discovered modern contemporary dance all
the movements are completely new for me
I'm trying to learn everything I can and
I've managed to find my feet through see
Jermaine ocwen a a star of senegalese
dance says she founded the dance academy
exactly for students like a lever de
vago a choreographer from New York
supporter I said these two women with
them recueil well with their brain to go
home that might be because the three
three months sessions are hard work the
training with renowned choreographers
from America and France is thur and
professional sinister salt we're the
only center in the whole of Africa that
invites dancers from a francophone angle
phone and Lusa phone countries over
phone we provide scholarships so that
students can realize their dream of
dancing colonel is ido a hotel or a
[ __ ] most of the money for the
scholarships comes from sponsors within
and outside Senegal the competition to
get a place at the school is tough
prospective students have to prove their
dance credentials but being socially
engaged can help too halawa de vaga was
considered because of his project with
street children he looks after several
abandoned children in the chat Ian
capital nada Jame know he's had to work
hard four months to earn their trust at
the dance girl he hopes to get new ideas
which he can incorporate in his work
shippuuden EP madhavi I want to give the
children hope that's my innermost need
I'm not doing it to make money I just
want to make the hard life these street
children have a little easier Oliva de
vago needs this training to expand his
street children project but first he has
to get used to the formal language of
African dance india coldest oddly many
students learn to interpret their own
traditional dances in a different way